speaking of love we took Halle Berry
back in time at her premiere for the new
TV series based on her iconic 1992
rom-com I remember that haircut
she's a very we were just all starting
little babies and trying to figure it
out just 25 then now 52 Hollies
executive producing the B et version so
will she make fans dreams come true and
reunite with Eddie Murphy
people want to see Angela and Marcus and
what happened I don't know I can't speak
for anybody else but maybe to a live
Groucho of age she'll be smarter more
confident but still be the girl next
door she's just as psyched for this
young crew including the stars cast as
her daughter and Robin Givens son who
played professionals tackling today's
modern world being young it didn't black
is cool but it's exhausting they're all
brand-new and sparkly and mad talented
and excited they're making their own
relevant important statement in like
2019 as for the fit and fierce Oscar
winner zone 2019 directing my first film
this year watch when I said it was beast
mode last time I saw you I'm in my
warrior mode this year we're gonna start
to heat it up I meant that this is a
really I think gonna be a really
defining time in my life for me to step
into another area that I'm completely
passionate about and I'm so ready for
[Music]